i don't know about you but it feels like
fortnite has been here forever so i
thought we should take a look back at
how far it has come since work began
over a decade ago and it's safe to say
the game has changed a great deal this
is the evolution of fortnite
our story begins in 2011 when epic were
finishing work on gears of war 3 and
began searching for their next project
the big inspirations were terraria and
minecraft and this was the first time we
ever saw fortnite a tiny teaser trailer
was shown to us all which encapsulated
how the building mechanic would work the
premise of fortnite was to survive 14
knights against the onrushing zombie
hordes then it took another three years
before we saw anything else behind
closed doors epic had a very basic
version of fortnite running destruction
was here melee combat 2 and check out
these things like granny scooters in the
zombie apocalypse i hope we get that in
the future
[Music]
jumping forward to 2014 april in fact
and gamers were given the chance to see
and play fortnite for the very first
time the stormchaser event was a super
secret meetup for super fans and future
content creators this was also the first
time the durburger restaurant was seen
in public little did we know it would
return four years later on july 8th it
was time for the rest of the world to
see what the game looked like it was
much slower back then yet we can still
see kyle looking hench and there's
jonesy with a bandana and goggles yeah
he looks a bit different and the art
style was not fully in place yet
building and editing were already the
core of the game but nobody was cranking
90s just yet and check out the traps and
in the sky there is a storm cloud this
wouldn't be newsworthy again until 2022
2014 also gave us the first animated
version of the fortnite logo you
probably recognize very cool by december
2014 the game was almost ready and the
public alpha was released over christmas
that year
on to 2015 now and in february we had a
brief insight into how epic made their
sound effects they lined up their
co-workers and had them pretend they're
in the walking dead this became the
sound of the husks which we've seen many
times over the years by march 2015
everything was falling into place
fortnite was starting to look like the
game it is today because this was when
they revealed the loot llama the loot
llama is a pinata that you get to whack
with your friends the llama has changed
a great deal over the years this one is
unique to save the world and also save
the world has a host of different
colored llamas to choose from they
should bring this llama to fortnite
battle royale and check out the supply
drops before it was a box of wood it was
this a sphere crash landed from space
filled with all the goodies we've
reached june 2015 and epic and apple
have teamed up together to create a demo
explaining the way fortnite works at the
time these two are good buddies and it
would be five years before these two
companies would be fighting it out in a
courtroom this demo showed us many of
the mechanics in fortnite save the world
like destroying everything and
collecting the materials and once again
storm clouds and lightning bolts were
all the rage
we've made it to 2016 epic release a
video about female constructors and how
they want to showcase a multitude of
body types this was the day penny was
born maybe that's more important to me
than you
by 2017 the fortnite world was complete
the art style was defined and epic were
ready to release the game e3 2017 was
the place we saw everything come
together character classes skills
weapons upgrades and crafting it was all
here july 25th 2017 the game finally
released but sadly sales weren't as
promising as epic had hoped so they had
a plan a free game mode to attract
people towards fortnite save the world
pubg and battle royale were the biggest
things in the game industry at the time
so epic decided to just follow in those
footsteps and that game mode kind of
took over the world
fortnite battle royale september 26 2017
by august 2017 the devs were working
hard to improve and evolve save the
world with the survive the storm game
mode which added the first ltm into
fortnite officially survive the storm
laid the groundwork for so many ltms in
the future a limited time mode players
can only get to for a small period of
time and oh boy those modes got so good
over the coming years moving on to
september 2017 the game mode only added
to bring attention to save the world had
its first ever update
welcome to the first battle royale dev
update welcome to the first battle
royale dev update i'm zach estep
producer on fortnite battle royale in
this production they promised to add
party chat they promised to bring stats
to the game and improve weapon accuracy
this would later become the first shot
accuracy most people loved in chapter
one and then approaching november 2017
the first ever fought nightmares dropped
halloween was embraced by the community
and by november the 6th over 20 million
players were part of the battle royale
craze which at the time was a world
record the item shop blew up as fans
were getting their first chance to rock
a unique skin the ghoul and skull
troopers came out and were the ultimate
flex and the fortnite machine started to
roll forward even at this early point
epic were already shifting focus away
from save the world and on to battle
royale the first notable update was a
launch pad added on november 14 2017.
then in early december we had the 5050
ltm half of the lobby versus the other
half of the lobby the world started to
love fortnite and then on december 13th
2017 the first ever battle pass was
unveiled season 2 of battle royale was
here and everyone had a reason to play
even without the purchased battle pass
as free loot tears were offered and kept
people who didn't want to spend real
world money still playing the game
season 2 brought us so many free updates
including the snowball launcher followed
by the boogie bomb all before christmas
2017. in only 100 days fortnite battle
royale had become one of the biggest
games in the world this was only the
beginning as epic games pumped out
update after update after update it
never stopped
[Music]
and now it's new year 2018 on january
17th there was a map update which
brought us tilted towers and a bunch of
new locations on the map then the chug
jug arrived only eight days later and
then the minigun all in the space of 14
days in the new year it was insane the
speed they were releasing these updates
as valentine's day approached
back-to-back save the world updates
dropped first to celebrate love and also
chinese new year but it was clear the
audience was crazy for battle royale and
then season 3 hit
john wick's unofficial brother arrived
and the theme was space travel which so
happened to be the first teaser towards
the story of fortnite this season we had
the hand cannon update hoverboards came
to save the world and a new ltm put 100
players into 5 teams of 20. suddenly
building became a key part of fortnite
thanks to turbo building the ability to
keep your finger down and continuously
and instantly build structures gun play
became the second most important thing
as players learnt to crank 90s and
forget to touch grass by march 2018
fortnite was a global phenomenon you
could not avoid it and that's when
fortnite battle royale came to mobile
phones epic were aware that updates kept
the audience enthused nobody was getting
tired of fortnite not yet anyway new
things were added weekly like the remote
mines and then the greatest update ever
the guided missile can we take a moment
to remember that guy r.i.p guided
missile 2018 to 2018. on march 30th
fortnite unveiled the buggy down contest
inviting us all to dance like fools the
winner had their emotes added to the
game the updates rolled on we had
vending machines porterfort and the
updated return of 50 vs 50. the fortnite
bandwagon was warming up for two more
huge updates first the replay feature
allowing us to go back into our games
and make our own cinematic content this
revolutionized content creation on
youtube but the following month made our
jaws hit the floor on may 8 2018 a new
ltm dropped like no other ever the
marvel infinity gauntlet landed and we
became the mad titan for a round hands
down one of the most fun game modes ever
made in fortnite unless you had to play
as one of the chitari on july 12th the
nintendo switch was finally given
support and those guys could put down
their phones and join us with their
console every gamer under the sun now
had a way to play fortnite from pc to
console to mobile phone and just in time
for jet packs and shopping carts to
arrive and then season five changed
everything again fortnite had evolved
into a storyline by this point one of
mystical travelers crashing down and
breaking space and time in game this
caused items to disappear and in real
life one of those appeared in the
californian desert a huge der burger
real life and fortnite had merged llamas
were found in europe and drift was
transported from our reality into
fortnite the weeks went on with records
broken new item after new item dropped a
rift to go a shockwave grenade a porter
fortress a new ltm high stakes the money
epic was making turned them into an
irresistible force then suddenly they
started to give back to the community
october the 11th 2018 saw the supporter
creator event when we bought something
with v-bucks our favorite creators got a
little something something from epic
games so now is a good time to say
please use code adamaru worth a try
right over a year into fortnite battle
royale and weekly new content continue
to rain down quad crashes another fort
nightmares balloons a crossover with
football the american version with the
egg hand thing as the year came to a
close we thought things were calming
down with a food fight ltm where pizzas
and burgers went to war it was strange
but great at the same time and then it
was a new year
now it's 2019 and in the first few weeks
of this new year the drift board was
added to fortnite alongside the baller
two forms of mobility the players have
asked for for a long time this could
have been enough but suddenly
marshmallow the musician just rocked up
and started playing a concert for us all
breaking even more records for fortnite
the moment we thought the updates must
stop came an even bigger one creative
mode released allowing us to build the
game modes we've always wanted making
battle royale no longer the core focus
for many players but for those who did
love the concept of br came something
extra special the fortnite world cup was
announced
[Music]
40 million dollars of winnings for us to
fight over the overall champion was
booger or booger
if courage jd gets to decide the
championship trophies could be found in
game which was another great touch which
brought real life and the game together
a game mode highly requested by the
community was added prop hunt and then
quickly forgotten oh well not everything
can hit john wick came to fortnite i
mean the real john wick not the fake
spanish version we had in 2017. the
world of entertainment began combining
with fortnite nike major laser they all
got in on the act along with rift zones
which brought us the world of
borderlands into fortnite complete with
cell shading aesthetics and then batman
and gotham appeared fortnite had
outgrown its boundaries and was daring
to do something unprecedented in gaming
for this though it needed a new
beginning
[Music]
chapter 2 arrived shortly after throwing
us into a black hole the subtle
storyline about space had gone full
circle and caused cataclysm and then we
awoke on a brand new island party royal
came to fortnite a place to hang out
with friends without guns and weapons
and instead just chill out and watch tv
and movies and play a few games by this
point crossovers became the focus of
fortnite and admittedly fatigue set in
for many players fortnite had shifted to
become a metaverse platform advertising
everything from the new star wars movie
to travis scott and even deadpool then
aquaman captain america and an entire
season dedicated to marvel comics love
it or hate it this was the season of
crossovers cars became drivable in
august 2020 and then one of the most
divisive court cases came around the
relationship between epic and apple had
collapsed epic didn't want to pay apple
for using their platform and apple said
they like money the two went to court
for a year and apple won because their
platform equals their rules one small
win for epic saw apple being forced to
let app developers use external payment
options but to this day fortnite remains
banned from the apple app store the free
fortnight movement was essentially
billionaires fighting billionaires for
billions of dollars but we got a cool
skin on september 17 2020 the ps5 and
xbox series x versions of fortnite were
added giving the game a new look only
slightly pc also received ray tracing
this month which made the game run
terribly but hey mirrors and windows now
looked cool and reflective the months
that followed were the sellout days of
fortnite and i bought all of it because
i'm a full great host master chief daryl
from the walking dead the predator the
terminator it was a weird and wonderful
time to be a fortnite fan we also began
giving epic money every month thanks to
the fortnite crew pack a monthly release
of v-bucks under skin and it was never
guaranteed to be a good skin the weekly
updates slowly became every two to three
weeks with only small changes applied
the innovation fortnite was known for
was finally becoming unsustainable don't
get me wrong though the occasional piece
of brilliance still arrived like sand
tunneling but fortnite began to stagnate
the year 2021 hit us in the face with
more new fortnite content epic began
leaning into the story way harder than
ever before agent jones was given a
voice during a live event and a guy who
looks an awful lot like the rock landed
too by march 2021 fortnite needed to do
something unique and they decided to go
into the comic book world fortnite and
dc combined to tell the story of batman
coming to the fortnite island and
escaping it soon after over six weeks we
watched as the caped crusader showed us
a step-by-step guide to escaping the
loop the genius here was that each comic
book was accompanied by a code to unlock
a cosmetic item in the game fortnite
reached another high during the invasion
season a huge alien mothership settled
above the island and the story and the
mechanics were linking together random
ufos and npcs playing an important part
both in the game and in the narrative
fortnite began to use their size to
highlight lessons from history such as
of march through time ltm showing a new
generation of gamers moments we really
should never forget meanwhile epic were
working on a new game mode in august
2021 the fortnite imposters mode arrived
a game mode completely based on among us
and although at first epic would deny
that they came to their senses and
acknowledged that among us was their key
inspiration this mode let us track down
fake io agents who had switched teams in
the fortnite story once again showing
game modes and story were a huge focus
for epic games at this point even the
rift tour a chance to watch ariana
grande sing and swing a huge hammer
became part of the core story as those
aliens were scanning our brains who'd
have thought that back in 2011. a few
more crossovers later and we made it
into chapter three december 2021 a new
island a new chance to update the game
and wow they really did it completely
turning the island on its head no less
this season saw the sliding mechanic
added an ar with a functioning scope was
added a reset to the pool of weapons and
so many new locations to look for the
story is now center stage with the seven
and i o the factors at work map updates
returned such as drills coming from the
underside of the island reaching all the
way to the top in january 2022 and now
the weather is a mechanic in fortnite
storm clouds can be seen building and
growing over time lightning bolts strike
the ground beneath us and a tornado is
now in game ripping apart pois and
sending everything it touches into the
air this was the evolution of fortnite
we've gone full circle from the first
ever storm cloud we saw in 2011 to the
modern day storm cloud we see in game
right now from a simple idea of
surviving 14 knights against zombie
hordes evolved into this battle royale
juggernaut the future of fortnite looks
bright with the upcoming creative 2.0
update which will give creators like you
and i more opportunities to decide the
future of fortnite if we want it to be
battle royale if we want it to be
something completely different the power
is in our hands i think it's safe to say
we've all had times where we haven't
loved fortnite and there's been times we
can't live without it the roller coaster
of being a fortnight fan continues 12
years and counting i'm adam thank you
very much for your time if you made it
this far i'm very impressed my voice
hurts now see you all soon bye-bye
[Music]